Trascrizione: Alessandra Piroddi
Revisore: Michele Gianella
(cit latina)
Cosa ci vuol dire Lucrezio,
con questi stupendi e sonori esametri
tratti dal suo poema "Sulla natura"?
Traduce in versi il ragionamento
di un grande filosofo della Magna Grecia,
Archita da Taranto,
vissuto intorno al V secolo a.C.
Archita si era posto un problema
che ci assilla dall'antichità,
e che è tuttora attuale,
come dimostra il tema
di questa serata, il confine.
Archita si chiedeva
se l'universo avesse un confine,
oppure si estendesse all'infinito.
Ecco il suo ragionamento,
che giunge a noi attraverso
i versi di Lucrezio.
"Se qualcuno si spingesse
fino alle rive estreme,
e scagliasse un dardo volante,
ritieni che questo,
vibrato con tutte le forze,
raggiunga il bersaglio
e voli oltre lontano,
oppure che qualcosa gli si opponga
e gli vieti l'andare?
Devi per forza ammettere
o una o l'altra ipotesi".
Lucrezio continua e conclude:
"Quid telo denique fiet",
"Che avverrà quindi del dardo? ".
Se prosegue indisturbato,
l'universo non ha confini;
ma se trova un ostacolo,
e rimbalza indietro,
significa che qualcosa c'è,
oltre il confine.
E allora, conclude Lucrezio con Archita:
"Nusquam possit consistere finis":
Non potremo mai trovare
il confine dell'universo.
Nel passato, i commentatori
di Lucrezio e di Archita
hanno interpretato questo ragionamento
come la dimostrazione
che l'universo fosse infinito.
Ma io credo che questa conclusione
semplice, quasi banale,
non renda merito all'acutezza
del pensiero del filosofo greco.
E oggi, anche alla luce
di quanto ci ha insegnato la cosmologia,
dovremmo piuttosto interpretare
questo ragionamento
come l'impossibilità di decidere
se l'universo sia finito o infinito.
Cosa ci dice infatti, oggi, la cosmologia?
Innanzitutto la cosmologia,
che è la scienza
di tutta la realtà fisica,
si basa per procedere,
per progredire nella conoscenza
del metodo scientifico moderno
inaugurato da Galilei;
e il metodo scientifico di Galilei
ha, come suo postulato,
quello di "rinunciare a tentare
l'essenza",  come diceva Galilei:
la scienza moderna rinuncia a indagare
la natura ultima della realtà,
ma si limita a studiare
le relazioni tra i fenomeni,
le relazioni tra i fenomeni misurabili,
che avvengono nello spazio e nel tempo.
Spazio e tempo.
Due entità, due forme pure
della nostra sensibilità
che da sempre ci interrogano
sulla loro natura
e sulla nostra relazione con loro,
con lo spazio e con il tempo.
Senza spazio, e senza tempo,
non potremmo definire i confini.
E dopo Lucrezio e Archita,
molti filosofi hanno indagato,
incessantemente,
la natura di queste due entità.
Finché, poco più di 100 anni fa,
un'altra mente eccelsa, Albert Einstein,
ci ha costretti a modificare radicalmente
quanto avevamo ereditato dalla scienza
e dalla filosofia dei secoli scorsi.
Lo spazio e il tempo
non sono più assoluti,
lo spazio non è più un contenitore
indifferente a quanto contiene.
Il tempo non scorre
ugualmente dappertutto.
Il contenuto dello spazio e del tempo,
la materia, i corpi materiali,
modificano la struttura
geometrica dello spazio,
e modificano anche lo scorrere del tempo.
Un concetto totalmente nuovo
di spaziotempo,
difficile da comprendere,
ma che ormai è quello
che dobbiamo accettare.
Con questo concetto nuovo di spaziotempo
diventa molto più
problematico, come vedremo,
definire un confine dell'universo.
E io credo che se Archita, o Lucrezio,
tornassero in vita oggi,
gioirebbero nel vedere
come le loro intuizioni di secoli fa
sono confermate in maniera così drammatica
dalla scienza moderna.
Ma si meraviglierebbero ancor di più,
e questo dovrebbe meravigliare
anche noi tutti,
nel constatare che questo nuovo
concetto di spaziotempo -
e dico spaziotempo
perché lo spazio e il tempo
non possono più essere considerati
separati uno dall'altro,
ma formano un continuum -
questo nuovo concetto,
quando viene applicato
alla totalità della realtà fisica,
quindi all'universo,
ne disvela la sua
caratteristica principale,
che era rimasta nascosta per secoli.
E cioè il fatto che l'universo evolve,
ha una storia che si dipana
da quasi 14 miliardi di anni,
passando attraverso fasi
diversissime tra loro
e aumentando sempre più la complessità.
Finché, dopo appunto 14 miliardi di anni,
in un minuscolo sperduto pianeta,
insignificante di fronte
alla maestosità dell'universo,
è emersa la vita biologica e la coscienza.
La cosmologia, la scienza moderna,
ci ha permesso di
ricostruire questa storia.
E lo ha fatto in maniera velocissima,
durante gli ultimi decenni,
anche grazie alla possibilità
di avere degli strumenti
estremamente sofisticati;
soprattutto i telescopi spaziali,
che osservando l'universo
dal di fuori dell'atmosfera
permettono di raccogliere i dati
che sulla Terra non arriveranno mai:
la luce ultravioletta, la luce infrarossa,
i raggi X, i raggi gamma.
Con tutte queste informazioni,
e con la teoria della relatività
generale di Einstein,
siamo capaci di ricostruire questa storia,
da quando l'universo era
un miscuglio informe
di particelle elementari e di energia,
con temperature ed energie
che non riusciranno mai a essere raggiunte
dai nostri laboratori terrestri.
E poi via via, per effetto
dell'espansione globale dello spazio,
la gravità, la forza di gravità,
ha preso il sopravvento
sull'energia delle singole particelle
e ha cominciato a creare
le prime strutture;
le prime stelle,
ammassi di stelle, galassie
e via via i pianeti attorno le stelle.
E all'interno delle stelle,
sostenute dalle reazioni nucleari
che avvengono al loro interno,
si sono formati gli elementi chimici
che oggi noi conosciamo
e di cui siamo fatti:
l'ossigeno, il carbonio, l'azoto,
il silicio, fino al ferro.
Tutti gli atomi di ferro
che in questo momento
circolano nelle nostre vene,
insieme all'emoglobina del sangue,
si sono formati all'interno di una stella,
o forse di altre, di molte stelle,
che un giorno, sacrificandosi
in un immane esplosione,
hanno sparso nell'universo
tutti questi nuovi elementi chimici
che prima non esistevano,
per formare poi pianeti,
e su questi pianeti far emergere la vita.
Oggi sappiamo che attorno ad ogni stella
che vediamo in cielo,
anzi attorno ad ogni stella dell'universo,
esistono pianeti,
molti dei quali sono simili,
per struttura e caratteristiche,
alla nostra Terra.
E quindi, l'ipotesi
che anche in altre zone dell'universo
si siano sviluppate quelle condizioni
che hanno permesso l'emergere
della vita biologica,
e quindi poi della coscienza,
come nel nostro pianeta,
diventa sempre più plausibile.
Anche se, bisogna dire
subito con chiarezza,
la possibilità di verificare
sperimentalmente questa ipotesi
è estremamente remota;
ma certamente, possiamo dire ormai
che un sottile filo rosso
unisce la nostra coscienza
all'evoluzione del cosmo.
Siamo inseparabili da questa evoluzione.
Allora, di fronte
a questa nuova situazione,
qual è la domanda fondamentale
che la nuova cosmologia ci pone?
Heidegger nella sua
"Introduzione alla Metafisica"
poneva questa domanda:
"Perché, in generale, esiste qualcosa
piuttosto che nulla?"
E affermava che questa era la prima
e più fondamentale di tutte le domande.
Ora questa si può modificare,
dicendo "Perché ciò che esiste
è sostanzialmente evolutivo?".
E la differenza non è affatto banale.
Perché se la realtà fisica
è essenzialmente evolutiva,
come abbiamo scoperto,
e se questa evoluzione
porta necessariamente
all'emergere della coscienza,
la domanda può essere
riformulata in questo modo:
"Perché in generale esiste la coscienza,
piuttosto che il nulla?".
Voi capite che diventa
sempre più impellente
che la filosofia
si riavvicini alla scienza,
dopo quattro secoli di separazione.
E la scienza, in particolare
la cosmologia,
deve riavvicinarsi alla filosofia
per dare un senso a quello
che via via sta scoprendo.
Questa separazione artificiale
tra pensiero scientifico
e pensiero umanistico
deve essere ricomposta;
come ai tempi gloriosi di Dante Alighieri,
quando nel suo poema scienza, filosofia,
teologia e arte formavano un tutt'uno.
Bene, lascio questa riflessione a voi
e torniamo ora al punto centrale
di questa serata, il confine.
Con tutte queste nuove informazioni,
con questo nuovo concetto
di spazio e tempo,
ha senso ancora parlare
di confine dell'universo?
Ha senso ancora chiederci
se l'universo sia finito o infinito?
Capite che se lo spazio e il tempo,
che definiscono i confini,
non possono essere separati
dalla realtà fisica,
e da noi stessi quindi,
questa domanda perde di significato,
diventa indefinita.
Dobbiamo allora forse chiederci
come possiamo definire questo,
come possiamo immaginare un confine
oltre al quale ci sia qualcos'altro,
quando il tempo e lo spazio
non appartengono a questo qualcos'altro,
perché sono legati al nostro universo;
esistono forse altri universi
con tempi e spazi diversi dal nostro?
Oppure dobbiamo pensare,
immaginare una metafisica
nella quale il chronos,
il tempo che scorre, non esiste
ma esiste solo il kairòs, il tempo sacro,
che unisce passato, presente e futuro?
In effetti alcuni cosmologi,
per uscire da questo dilemma,
subito seguiti da filosofi entusiasti,
hanno ipotizzato i cosiddetti multiversi:
innumerevoli o infiniti universi
diversi dal nostro, paralleli al nostro,
con i quali non potremo, però,
mai entrare in comunicazione.
È un'ipotesi affascinante, sicuramente;
ma, dobbiamo subito
affermare con chiarezza,
non potrà mai essere
verificata scientificamente.
Quindi non è un'ipotesi scientifica,
ma è un'ipotesi filosofica.
Potremmo paragonarla
agli antichi miti delle origini:
il multiverso come Enuma Elish,
come Gilgamesh, come Bereshit.
Di fronte a questa situazione
potremmo essere un po' presi
dallo sconforto,
nel vedere che non riusciamo
a stabilire un confine.
Ma forse, riflettendo,
ci accorgeremmo che questo
nostro sconforto
è generato dalla nostra
pretesa, o illusione,
che il metodo scientifico
sia in grado di risolvere ogni problema,
che sia in grado di conoscere tutto.
E invece dobbiamo, una volta di più,
ricordare il manifesto galileiano:
"Rinuncio a tentare l'essenza".
Dobbiamo comprendere
che la realtà fisica ultima
rimarrà sempre misteriosa.
E quello che noi possiamo fare invece,
molto più fruttuosamente,
è studiare le relazioni.
Studiare quindi,
invece che pensare al confine,
immaginare quale sia la relazione nostra
con l'Universo evolvente;
la relazione del fenomeno umano,
come amava chiamarlo Teilhard de Chardin,
e l'universo evolvente.
Questo è il vero confine,
il vero confine che è forse
quello che dobbiamo analizzare,
è quello tra la materia e lo spirito.
Un confine artificiale
che ci è stato tramandato
dalla filosofia classica,
ma che comincia a scricchiolare
di fronte alle nostre
nuove cognizioni sul cosmo.
E forse va sostituito
a una graduale evoluzione.
Forse non siamo differenti dalla materia;
il cuore della materia,
come chiamava Teilhard de Chardin.
Certamente, per indagare
questo nuovo confine,
come abbiamo già detto,
non possiamo limitarci a utilizzare
il metodo scientifico.
Dobbiamo, umilmente, riconoscere
che dobbiamo rinunciare
a sconoscere tutto,
ma possiamo sicuramente affidarci
non solo al metodo scientifico,
ma anche alla filosofia, alla poesia,
al mito e volendo, alla teologia.
Grazie.
(Applausi)